let's look back on division around
weekend we have a mail bag that we're
going to pop open and this leads into
the first question the conversation
about the saints from enma perez 09 why
didn't every team do what the buccaneers
did and challenge drew brees to either
throw it through a tight window
underneath or try to throw it deep chris
well i think a lot of teams did try to
do that you know we saw kansas city
going to new orleans and and and really
do a lot of those similar type things
it's not always easy and you don't
always have the manpower to do that
against the new orleans saints you know
within playing them you got to worry
about their great offensive line their
run game and doing all that the bucks
have a team that they can trust their
defensive line to stop that run game but
i think really what ultimately came down
to it is yeah they watched their first
two matchups against brees they realized
especially in that blowout loss that
they were picked apart playing zone
coverages they played a little bit more
aggressively in the second half
as far as man-to-man is concerned
and i think they went into this game
going wait
we got to make drew brees make throws
and and into tight windows and can't let
him just pick apart zones and that's
that was a difference and that's been
something we talked about a lot
throughout the year right mike i mean it
didn't always end up in losses for the
saints but you and i talked about a lot
where the threat of them not having a
downfield passing game was an issue and
why they sputtered against the bears
early in the year and the carolina
panthers when they won 27-24 and the
overtime win against the chargers all of
them did these these type of things that
we saw the bucks do the bucks just came
out with the win
hey i look look at it this way i mean
first of all
we saw what happened to supplement the
the inability to get the ball down the
field they would go with taysom hill
we've seen that over the past couple of
years but when it was time for the trick
play
the play they
borrowed from the chicago bears the week
earlier
you bring in jameis winston to throw
that ball you know i mean i think it's
got even a greater element of surprise
if you split drew brees wide on that
play you don't expect drew brees i know
right throw that ball yeah because when
winston comes in you're immediately on
guard for something as a defense it it
makes it harder to pull off the ruse
when oh but here comes winston
something's going on and they're putting
winston out wide something's going on so
uh yeah they they don't trust the arm
strength and the arm strength just isn't
there it for me it first flagged in that
division around game against the eagles
two years ago when they had two weeks to
get ready for the game they knew exactly
what the first play was going to be and
it was underthrown ted ginn was open
trayvon leblanc jumped up and
intercepted it and it it it created an
opportunity for the eagles to get up i
think they were 14 nothing in that game
so yes
even got their shoes on right so uh and
that throw was the spark so yeah we've
seen it and and i think that's one of
the reasons why um even if drew brees
wanted to come back i don't i don't
think even though mickey loomis has said
he can play as long as he wants to
that's just being polite i think the
saints are ready to move on right i mean
i would hope that drew brees can see it
for what it is too
and just be real about it and go okay
you know yeah i'm not the same guy
and at some point you got to start
asking yourself wait am i helping the
team or am i hurting the team and i
think that's a legitimate question that
he could look in the mirror and ask
right now and i'm not trying to be
disrespectful that way or anything like
that you know mike you want to check out
that like let's bring up those dots on
that play again if we can just to show
it because it's really interesting too
mike where like breeze has good
protection and we can rewind it to the
start here where
you know you see alvin kamara he's gonna
split those two tight ends right up the
middle
one of the things he's got a great
pocket and as it goes mike you'll see if
brees waits on this
like
this i i he might score a touchdown i
don't know what you could see the corner
the safety they have spread they went
away you know this is now the ball's
been intercepted and they're running
down the sideline but it really you talk
about a game-changing play yeah it was
huge for the bucks i mean it it's it's
this close or brees just patting the
ball one more time and waiting to go
five more yards and he might hit his
head on the goal post uh that's just how
crazy the the the game of football is
game of inches but
but it was starting to collapse around
him and if i recall correctly there was
that moment where you know he had the
bloody arm i mean he got he got knocked
hard one play and and maybe that's that
got him just getting it out of his hand
sooner than he would have and here's
what i'll say about drew brees because
yeah i look we have to respect one of
the great careers of all time and i have
extra respect for somebody
who
takes whatever god-given abilities he
has
and gets
more out of them than anyone ever would
have imagined when you consider he was
the trailblazer for short quarterbacks
and and he kept going and going and he
had the shoulder injury that would have
ended anyone else's career quite
possibly he fought through that and then
unlocked this higher level of potential
he was you know cast aside by the
chargers welcome to new orleans became
one of the most important figures in the
history of that city
and and the future potential for a guy
like drew brees given that will that he
has and the ability and the desire and
the work ethic i mean he can do whatever
he wants to do i remember talking to him
about at the super bowl a few years ago
he wants to do different things he can
do anything he's like in that same
peyton manning mode where this guy can
do anything he wants to do
once he gets that focus he's going to be
successful it's just a matter of what he
chooses to do all right who will the
saints choose to be their next
quarterback we assume it's going to be
taysom hillary jameis winston
red brood has a question about the
possibility of desean watson being the
next starting quarterback for the new
orleans saints and also much love from
the uk much love to the uk thank you for
that red brood
here's my desean watson story because
this was before your time on this
program
houston
almost four years ago interviewing sean
payton
and deshaun watson just finished up at
clemson
and got done with peyton
and here comes deshaun watson and
peyton moved faster
than i would have ever expected to see
sean payton move he was boom on to sean
watson talking he was fascinated by
deshaun watson but but desean watson was
on the board
when
sean payton
made his 11th overall pick in the 2017
draft patrol homes wasn't i think it
would have taken my homes i think at the
end of the day he decided there is a gap
between mahomes and watson so
fast forward four years later i don't
think that the saints are going to be in
the deshaun watson derby if it comes
down to it i i won't i don't think so i
i mean they are one of the teams where i
think you know for me the thing i think
about with deshawn watson is it's not
gonna to me it's not a team that's like
the jets i know there's a lot of jets
fans they want desean watson you know
what you'll be with desean watson four
and 12 just like the texans were with
deshaun you got way too many hulls so
you'll just be the jets with deshawn
watson
sorry
that you're not the type of team and i
guarantee you'd say no to getting traded
to you guys anyway yes all right so
sorry jets that way the teams that are
going to look to trade for them though i
do think our teams like the saints we're
go our team's in place we're really good
as far as how we're built we're just
missing
that guy or that position and that to me
is going to be the team that kind of
team at least in formula that will trade
for deshaun watson i think it's i
wouldn't trade for desean watson if i
have 75 holes to fill on my team and now
i'm gonna trade you know 40 of those
assets away to get one guy and we're
never gonna fill those holes in the team
uh i i wouldn't think about it that way
so that's where it is interesting and
i like the saints i don't know mike like
i thought about this a little yesterday
i feel like it'll be taysom hill right
as a starting quarterback
i would think they'd pay j miss winston
a pretty penny to be a high quality
backup once again too because right i
don't think anybody's gonna bring
jamison to be a starter this year so i
still think the best avenue for him is
to stay with the saints
taysom hill plays quarterback there's a
great chance you're going to get to
start and play games i mean he barely
plays now and he's got a bruised knee
and he's had a concussion this year and
all those issues so
i would think we might see the same two
quarterbacks with the saints next year
and and the evidence is there because
sean payton explained that taysom hill
got the starts when drew brees was
injured because sean payton had given
taysom hill his word that that's what
would happen this year
and
sean payton also gave jameis winston his
word that winston would be in the mix to
compete for the starting job post breeze
so when they got jameis winston come to
town last year this wasn't a one-year
thing this was a come this year
practice you'll get to play some
and and that'll be part of the
evaluation of the competition that goes
into 2021 so yeah i i don't know maybe
you see an offense that uses both guys
like we've seen an offense that uses
both guys with breeze and hill it'll
just be hill and winston moving forward
by the way
matt casey points out that desean
watson's official instagram account
liked a picture of the new york post
back page from monday that said the jets
should do whatever it takes to acquire
uh sean watson oh jesse wants to come
matt casey is a jets fan i think he
needs that that's the fans
that's just
that's here's deshawn watson is stirring
the he wants to have yeah uh lots of
people
he and well he wants it to be
uh he wants to speak it into existence
eventually i was going to speak into
existence the phrase i was looking for
which is he wants to speak it into
existence i think he wants miami you and
i at birth or both heard miami is the
the focal point but you know for the
texans to do it it can't just be miami
the texans need to have multiple teams
at the auction
where the desean watson contract is held
up
and they have their paddles
and and the the texans get their maximum
price before they let him go and that's
the dilemma for watson because you don't
want your next team to give up so much
that
your next team's going to be four and 12
right with you right you don't want to
gut the roster or the future draft picks
so there's a sweet spot there somewhere
it's not going to be easy but it's
obvious that desean watson wants out hey
post script to the day that
that i was interviewing sean payton and
then deshawn watson came up to the set
and those two talked at some point later
that day this guy who slid down from a
beanstalk came over and introduced
himself to me big big guy with a giant
head i can't remember i was the same day
there that that was uh
in the huge convention center there in
houston texas right i remember that
right uh i do i can remember yesterday
i know i was like who is this jerker
over here
that was what i was saying who's this
this guy's coming over and he's trying
to intimidate me and he's
looking down on me it's like get out of
here you big lummocks
i can't wait till i can get around you
again and just going to put you in a
headlock and give you a good mess up
your hair and do it all i can't wait
wait no wait a minute i can't wait till
i get around you again and throw up in a
garbage can is that how you were going
to finish your thought because the last
time we were together that's what you
did yes hey mike brooke good to see you
all right uh thank god that footage
isn't queued up to be rolled up it's
coming
like it used to be i know if i talk long
enough maybe we'll see it all right next
question from simcinny has anyone seen
michael thomas i thought nobody could
guard him
and let's double that one up with john
pascal's question more likely to be
traded this offseason michael thomas or
obj i like that question oh that's uh
well michael thomas i doubt he was
totally 100
in that playoff game and everything like
that but again we saw some of his flaws
too there you know he he's not a guy
again that's going to scare and back
people off that way he's not he's not
people aren't scared of michael thomas
catching a slant and running for 70-yard
touchdown we i don't think we've ever
seen that you know very rare you see him
really catch just a straight go route
and do those type of things there has to
be a certain way he's used in a certain
offense that makes him effective
you know i've said this many times if
you ask michael thomas to go up to
the the seattle seahawks and do the same
things dk metcalf does he wouldn't be
nearly the same guy he's not a guy
that's just a physical
specimen where you have to worry about
whoa he's gonna run by me and just
whether he catches a short pass or a
long pass and i have to worry about that
he's a route runner he's tough he's
physical he can work the middle of the
field that's the kind of player he is
that's why i've always said i don't
think he's the best receiver in football
even though he's phenomenal but mike
what do you think i don't know i mean
both of these guys i would think are
gonna get phone calls
uh as far as trade offers as far as
thomas and obj
as we reported during the season before
the trade deadline thomas's people were
calling around to select teams
saying make an offer please for michael
thomas this is when he was injured this
is when i remember he got suspended but
not really suspended by the saints got
into a fight with cj gardner johnson
then again who hasn't uh because i don't
know who to really blame there but but
there was something going on with the
saints and michael thomas then
and you know when you look back at
recent history antonio brown tweeted his
way out of pittsburgh stefan diggs one
message the day they extended kirk
cousins diggs is like i'm out i'm gone
and they traded him it's about you know
matching up with a quarterback and it
worked very well when it was thomas and
brees and if thomas doesn't believe in
the offense moving forward if the saints
don't believe in him if the if if the sa
remember the stories that came out about
thomas's you know he'd been kind of
difficult to deal with and he was a
problem for like pr staff and and and
you know once sean payton reaches his
breaking point it's done now i know you
know peyton has to play it right
strategically you don't want to give the
guy away but hey
i see urban meyer in jacksonville and he
recruited michael thomas and michael
thomas played for him at ohio state and
uh and they got all those draft picks
and they got all that cap space in
jacksonville um that that's one that i
would at least keep an eye on right out
of the gates yeah i agreed i mean i
would think that you know teams with
everything that you just mentioned that
went on are gonna make a call down there
we'll see you're right we don't know how
happy he is there all together um but
if you had a bet which one gets traded
who would you bet michael thomas or obj
um
i you know what a problem i would say
obj because i think his contract's
easier to move and i think there'd be a
bigger market for obj than michael
thomas right now i have the same thought
i guess the only thing that makes me
pause is just because of the acl injury
but i don't know if that'll make a big
difference right especially because it
happened early in the year for obj and i
would think that you know he'll be
full 100 you know miles per hour go by
the time training camp and the regular
season roll around uh but it's going to
be interesting and really
cleveland playing their cards right
there with the obj conversation they
have said everything right stefanski
continues to back him and say all the
right things because if he is back then
yeah hey you want to use him and
certainly he's still talented and
everything like that but he's also
letting it be known that yeah they like
him to where you're going to have to
trade something to get them off that
team
but and that time is coming quickly we
got word yesterday there won't be a
scouting combine which is a shame but
there still will be free agency and
trades and that's march 17 that's fewer
than two months away that we're going to
reshuffle the deck on 2021 and that's
when the window opens for trades with
guys like michael thomas obj and plenty
of others who are out there at steelers
maddie has a question what did the
chiefs do differently than the steelers
in defending the browns or was it just
that they tackled and the steelers
didn't well yeah the the i think there's
some of that i think the biggest thing
is not even about the defense
it's not it's you know kansas city's
offense didn't do some of the dumb
things that the pittsburgh steelers
offense did that was really the story of
that game you know i know we all want to
like look at the steelers and go oh they
let up all those points in that football
game i would go no dumb interceptions by
big ben the snap over the head all of
that
i don't care who you are you could bring
back the 85 bears they were going to let
up some points in that football game in
the positions they were put in but the
chiefs spagnolo is very creative he
really is they probably have more depth
on the defensive line that's what i'll
say more than anything than the
pittsburgh steelers there's more depth
there there's more big people in general
and the chiefs are just like we talk
about their whole team and their offense
their defense fits the mold too mike you
say it out all the time just
when there's a challenge
posed to them they rise to it it doesn't
matter oh the two-headed monster maybe
the best running back in football is
coming in nowhere no problems no
problems we'll stop it chris jones nandi
all these big dudes boom boom boom boom
you're not running on us uh they're
they're they're really like amazing that
way and how they can just turn on the
switch and shut something out
you know one thing that dawned on me
yesterday chris about that browns chiefs
game i mentioned it last night on pftpm
and i wrote something about it
we talked all last week about how the
browns needed to shorten the game
minimize possessions to deal with
patrick mahomes and the chiefs yeah and
then when mahomes got injured they
should have flipped it the other way
they had two drives after mahomes exited
that first drive that resulted in the
touchdown that made it 22 to 17 consumed
eight minutes and 17 seconds of clock
time
you you want more opportunities when
it's mayfield versus chad henny you want
more times for both teams to have the
ball and and then we saw that last drive
we talked yesterday about that last
drive where they had the ball from eight
minutes down to 417 to move it 12 yards
and then punted and didn't get it back i
i'm just i'm stunned for as much respect
and admiration as i have for what kevin
stefanski did in his first year as a
coach that they didn't realize they had
to flip they had to they had to speed up
the the the the plays have a greater
sense of urgency and have more
possessions not fewer down the stretch
because if there would have been more
possessions for both teams the browns
would have caught him without patrick
mahomes well yeah i i i hear you it's
just you know again i i'm not going to
go crazy on kevin stefanski you know the
the chiefs defense is playing damn good
i mean that 18 play drive i'm sure they
would have liked to got down there in
half the time or half the plays but damn
would they have to convert three fourth
downs or two fourth downs another third
down i mean
kansas city's defense did not play bad
in that drive that was really just like
two good units going at it and baker
mayfield made some unbelievable throws
into some tight windows and all that and
and i hear you with the the the end of
the game situation i get it but i think
they're also looking at it going hey we
just moved the ball methodically on this
team we think we can do it again and the
chiefs are not exactly famous
uh and without patrick holmes for
running out a clock and doing that so i
think they played that percentage right
there it backfired it didn't work but
it's not one that i'm gonna sit here in
the off season and second guess all the
time speaking of the chiefs chief
boyardee points out that tyron matthews
seemed to be flying into the screen at
100 miles per hour every play yesterday
that guy doesn't get the credit that he
deserves he he is awesome he doesn't fit
any one box but he's always he's kind of
got that and i was talking to somebody
about this yesterday as it relates to
devon white that it's the devin white
mickey fitzpatrick troy palamalu tyron
matthew
they just have a sixth sense
of where the ball is going to be
definitely and they tend to be around it
yeah agreed you know i wouldn't say
jamal adams he's in that conversation
that kind of guy right it's it's it's
tremendous instincts it's probably a
million hours of backyard football
growing up and then it's guys who love
football who study it during the week in
the film like that's tyrone matthew is
not physically the player he was five
years ago you know i've heard ray lewis
talk about this before you've heard
other great players talk about it but
his read and recognition skills at this
point of his career are off the charts
and he makes plays sometimes where you
just go
i don't know how he diagnosed that so
quick quickly and realized it was that
play but it's his study his love for the
game and just his natural given
instincts like a sixth sense like you're
talking about
yeah just incredible and uh yeah he's
got a super bowl ring and uh two games
away from another yeah what a story
matthew yeah
well and and yeah the the way he was
kind of cast aside by lsu the cardinals
chance on him they kept him for a while
and they cut him loose and boy you know
you think back to a couple of years ago
when it was tyrant matthew and earl
thomas as the marquis safeties on the
market and uh the chiefs got the right
one and the ravens all due respect got
the wrong one uh at j amunde why do
teams thinking of the ravens wait until
halftime to make adjustments the bills
were giving them short passes and taking
away the run but they still didn't
adjust until it was too late chris yeah
yes i mean i won't disagree with that
but the ravens are always going to go
down with what brought them there and
that was the run game in doing that they
had just got into
the short passing game and things going
that way you know let's not forget it
was 10-3 and they had the ball at the
eight yard line you know they they had
found out okay this is how we're gonna
have to move the ball lamar did make a
few throws
now the next thing is just getting
better at all of it you know the offense
needs to help out lamar they need to
find a few receivers and like we heard
willie sneed yesterday and we talked
about that a little you know lamar's got
to get better too you know even like the
play before the interception and the
pixel hey the pick six you would like
lamar not to stare down that mark
andrews down the middle and kind of see
the whole picture and he would have been
able to see that tyron johnson was
playing between willie snead and mark
andrews just reading his eyes and you
could kind of just play two-on-one
basketball but but the other thing too
is the pipe before that remember the
pipe before that mic where jerry hughes
gets the pressure and they got a wide
open hollywood brown you know coming
across there it's going to be an easy
touchdown but jerry hughes gets to lamar
and he's got to throw it off his back
foot and doesn't get it there that to me
is like the next step for lamar is that
kind of stuff just right there he's
amazing football player but like josh
allen rogers mahomes they make that
third down throw where they're or the
second down throw where they're fading
away and somebody's in their face and
they throw the ball to hollywood brown
they make that and that's where he just
got to become a little bit more of a
complete passer thrower to where they
can scare teams that way and the offense
got to help them
important question next at noceto can i
get a damn okay for the packers o line
damn damn okay
we will that was i mean it's impressive
we both have waxed poetically about them
here
and
they imposed their physicality on the
rams and we didn't even hear about aaron
donald all game long really and that's
the thing i love about the rams if it's
going to be interesting and different i
mean what i love about the packers
what's going to be interesting and
different about
this
tampa game this time around
tampa the last time could kind of play
oh let's play a bear front and we'll
play coverage
it's just not going to be that easy now
i don't think you could just sit there
and play coverage and thinking damacan
sue and jpp and them are going to stop
the run not not against this green bay
team the way they're doing it right now
we've seen them
every week the last month where you load
the box they still run it and run it
successfully
and i think that's where they're a
different animal than week six of this
year
and the other thing too about aaron
donald he he wasn't okay
damn he wasn't okay
yeah no i mean
okay
aaron donald was injured
clearly and it was funny because
you you know that the coach is engaged
in blatant bs when the announcers call
bs during the game on the coach because
at halftime mcveigh denied that aaron
donald was playing limited snaps
that he was yeah yeah of course you are
and and look i respect aaron donald for
trying to fight through it he was really
emotional after the game you only get so
many opportunities to try to build your
legacy and hey
this guy was drafted in 2014. this isn't
like he just showed up two years ago
he's getting closer to the end he's
closer to the end in the beginning when
you consider how physical he's played
and he's been getting hit by two and
three guys every snap so um you know
these opportunities are not going to be
automatic and and uh he was very
confident about where that rams team was
going to be but the packers stepped up
the offensive line was really good and i
remember when david bachtiari got
injured and that word started to
circulate you know if you're a packers
fan that's that that pit in your gut
where you're just like oh the season was
going great and now it's done right
haven't missed a beat no haven't missed
a beat after making bacteria the highest
paid offensive lineman in the history of
the league they haven't missed a beat
without him i'm not saying they
shouldn't have paid him right i'm just
saying this is a testament to the
offensive line coach the head coach and
the backups who came in and got it done
yeah all right one more real quickly
eru 811 and this is a topic that we
touched on briefly yesterday why isn't
there a song
for tom brady seems like a self scout
thyself thing for chris not even a fan
but think he deserves one something
auto-tuned feels like it fits now i've
suggested that the barry manilow song
mandy be retooled
for tom brady i think it would be very
effective it's very wistful and it would
be an opportunity for you to acknowledge
your past failure to appreciate the
greatness that is tom brady shut up okay
shut up i appreciate don brady a lot
yeah the the song thing was totally
organic it came from aaron rodgers
originally and me being stupid of my
podcast you know after that game he beat
the bears back in the day with one leg
and through those touchdown passes on
one of the opening sunday nights here on
nbc a few years ago i started singing
songs about like how amazing he was and
doing that and then i've really kept it
to the younger
new fresh guys as you know it's been
mahomes and watson and josh allen and
that kind of stuff i do think about the
brady one though i do every now and then
and i have people ask me a lot so i i
feel like to me though
it's got to be something like
like he's the general the commander it's
too pristine it needs to be like you
know like tom brady's coming to town
again hurrah hurrah something's crazy
like that he's like he's the he's the
commander in chief something like that
but i'll figure it out eventually
all right uh well you better figure it
out if he wins this weekend we're going
to need to debut something in advance oh
okay
and and and uh hey
yeah it's just incredible
what he's done over the last six games
including the playoff game 318.8 yards
per game 9.4 yards per attempt
and uh 16 touchdowns one interception
that completion percentage 64 8. it's
been down near 50 the past couple of
games i love it i love getting the ball
down the field no risk get no biscuits
exactly it's putting pressure on the
defense to me that the more is not
passing yards per temp the impressive
thing with him is completions the yards
per completion when he's dropping back
the throw throw they're looking to make
big plays and that helps your running
game and everything else and the defense
is shaking in their boots because
they're always worried about you making
some aggressive play that way and that's
that to me is right now where football
is at we're done 72 and all that thing i
think that's going away it's aggressive
it's homers and strikeouts like we were
talking about yesterday i think big
plays are the name of the game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports